nos dicen ésta es la gráfica de igual a
3 medios a la equis y esta es la gráfica
usa la gráfica para encontrar la
solución aproximada a tres medios a la x
igual a 5 pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta antes de que lo
resolvamos juntos vamos a resolverlo
juntos ya nos dieron una pista sobre
cómo resolver esto nos dan la gráfica de
igual a 3 medios a la equis esto nos da
la pista porque nos dicen que
encontremos la solución aproximada por
lo que podemos resolver esta ecuación de
manera aproximada usando la gráfica y la
forma en la que podemos hacer esto es
tomar cada uno de los lados de la
ecuación y establecer los como una
función podemos poner que es igual a
cada lado de la ecuación por lo que si
decimos que es igual al lado izquierdo
tenemos que es igual a tres medios a la
equis que es la ecuación original de la
gráfica y si decimos que es igual al
lado derecho tenemos que es igual a 5 lo
que podemos graficar
algo interesante es que si podemos
encontrar un valor de x que tenga el
mismo valor
en estas dos ecuaciones esto significa
que ambas gráficas se van a inter secar
si tenemos el mismo valor y para el
mismo valor de x en ambas ecuaciones
significa que 3 medios a la x va a ser
igual a 5 así que podemos fijarnos en
donde se intersectan y darnos una idea
aproximada de cuál es ese valor de x
aquí podemos verlo y parece que x es
aproximadamente igual a 4 si quisiéramos
podríamos probar ese valor en la
ecuación para ver si funciona tres
medios a la cuarta potencia es igual a
cinco veamos tres a la cuarta es igual a
81 2 a la cuarta es 16 eso se acerca
bastante a 5 16 por 5 es 80 no es exacto
pero se acerca bastante si tienen una
calculadora gráfica con la que puedan
acercar la gráfica verían que x es
ligeramente diferente a x igual a 4
vamos a resolver otro ejemplo la clave
aquí es encontrar
aproximadas a las ecuaciones por medio
de las gráficas aquí nos dicen ésta es
la gráfica y es igual a este polinomio
la gráfica está aquí usa la gráfica para
responder las siguientes preguntas
cuántas soluciones tiene la siguiente
ecuación x al cubo menos 2 x cuadrada
menos x más 1 igual a menos 1 pausa en
el vídeo y piensen en ello
al pensar en soluciones a esto decimos
imaginemos dos funciones una es igual a
x al cubo menos 2 x cuadrada - x + 1 que
ya tenemos graficado aquí y digamos que
la otra ecuación o función es igual a
menos 1 cuántas veces se intersectan
estas dos funciones
esto nos dirá cuántas soluciones tenemos
esto es igual a menos 1 y estas son las
soluciones a esta ecuación tenemos una
dos y tres tenemos tres soluciones ahora
veamos la segunda pregunta cuántas
soluciones tiene la siguiente ecuación
es todo esto igualados hacemos lo mismo
es la misma ecuación x al cubo menos 2 x
cuadrada menos x más 1 pero ahora es
igual a otra función en donde es
igualados ya igualados está aquí por
arriba podemos ver que esto solo
intersec a una vez a la gráfica en un
punto que igual a todo esto la solución
es sólo una
la clave aquí es estos son pantallazos
de ejercicios de khan academy en donde
tendríamos que introducir uno o en el
ejemplo anterior
tendríamos que introducir cuatro pero
estos son ejemplos donde tomamos una
ecuación de una variable establecemos
ambos lados de la ecuación como
funciones independientes iguales allí
las gráfica moss y luego nos fijamos en
donde se intersectan ya que los valores
de x en donde se intersectan serán las
soluciones de la ecuación original y una
gráfica es una forma útil de aproximar
el valor que tendrían las soluciones en
especial si tenemos una calculadora
gráfica o algo parecido